kim kardashian is showing off her kids
luxury
mini car collection and we're straight
up jealous over it
it was so so so so amazing
over the weekend the mama 4 gave us a
look at what exactly
north saint chicago and somme are riding
in
and it did not disappoint sharing to
instagram the mini vehicles in her
garage
which include a few atvs a lamborghini
two mercedes g-wagons a mustang and if
you look closely in the back
a mini motorcycle i mean it's so much
fun
not only do kim's kids have sick rides
they also have a
full kitty town in their backyard yeah
check it out that's the west diner a
fire station
and yes there's even a kkw beauty
boutique
you have to go see it and of course this
isn't the first time
kim has basically made us feel well like
we're not billionaires
starting off with her regal master
bathroom showing off her stunning view
that's basically an art installation
that's our patio out there
our whole ceiling is a light box
bathtub that fits all of our kids
and our shower and let's not forget this
interesting feature in her sink that at
first had us like
um how does that even work so
eight versions of this prototype sink
was made
and it does actually like slightly slope
down that you can kind of see
and there's a slit for the water and it
goes in
you can put it on as high pressure as
you want and no backsplash will come up
but nothing compares to her kitchens yes
plural
a kitchen and a full restaurant quality
kitchen which kim decided to show us
after this photo of one of her seemingly
empty fridges went viral
since the inside of my fridge is so
baffling and i saw all these news
reports i'm gonna give you guys
a tour of my fridge and guys
i have walk
in refrigerator
where we keep all of our fresh organic
produce
all of our meals you guys know i eat
plant-based now
so all of our stuff is in here
aside from hanging with the kids at home
kim has been keeping herself busy and
adjusting to her new normal
amid her divorce from husband kanye west
earlier this month a source told e.t
that the reality star
has been doing her best to surround
herself with her family and good friends
be social go out and of course take care
of her children
i do want to make sure that i have
enough time for everybody
having kids is just there's no way to
describe it but it's a lot